Schönen.
Guten Tag.
Jusso, bist du mein Name?
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt in dieser Station.
Ja, guten Abend oder guten Tag.
Geht es um Sie oder um Ihr Kind?
Nein, ich habe ja nicht.
Hier sehen Sie, ich habe meinen Säugling dabei, mein kleines Mädchen.
Und die gefällt mir gar nicht.
Also, ich bin ganz aufgeregt.
So etwas hat sie noch nie gehabt.
Und Sie müssen Sie unbedingt mal anschauen.
Ja, ich werde um Sie gut kümmern.
Aber ich möchte zuerst ein paar Fragen
zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie alt ist Sie?
Meine Tochter ist ziemlich genau sechs Monate alt.
Sechs Monate alt.
Und können Sie Ihr Name sagen?
Ja, Sie heißt Marie.
Und unsere Familienname ist Waldeck.
Könnten Sie die beiden Namen Buch stammieren?
Ja, Marie schreibt man M-A-R-I-E.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Waldeck, W-A-L-D-E-C-K.
Und Marie ist natürlich bei mir mitversichert.
Ja, natürlich.
Und wissen Sie, wie groß ist sie?
Sie muss ungefähr 65 Zentimeter groß sein.
75.
65.
60.
Und wie schwer ist es?
Ja, ich habe sie jetzt länger nicht gewogen.
Wir waren zwar bei der Vorsorge, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau.
Ich denke mal, sie wiegt so sieben Kilo oder zwischen sechs und sieben Kilo.
Alles klar.
Und was fühlt Sie zum heute?
Ja, also schauen Sie, die Kleine ist ganz apathisch.
Und sie hat auch ordentliche Beule am Kopf.
Sie ist mir vom Wickeltisch gefallen.
Das war ganz blöd.
Ich habe mich gestreckt.
Der Windeleimer stand soweit weg.
Und ich wollte die Windel da reinwerfen.
Dann habe ich sie mit einer Hand festgehalten.
Und dann ist sie mir einfach so runtergewutscht und.
Mit einer lag sie unten.
Und sie hat ganz furchtbar geschrien.
Und ich habe sie versucht zu trösten.
Und mit einer ist sie ganz still geworden.
Und das war ja noch schlimmer als das Schreien.
Und jetzt.
Ja, sie reagiert gar nicht mehr so richtig gut.
Und und sie wollte jetzt auch gar nicht mehr trinken.
Und ich bin also.
Ja, ich bin in ganz großer Sorge.
Dann habe ich mich auch.
Ja, als das losging, das habe ich gedacht.
Ja, mal einen Moment warten.
Vielleicht vielleicht erholt sie sich.
Aber ist sie nur ein bisschen erschrocken.
Aber wenn ist das passiert?
Das ist jetzt gut zwei Stunden.
Vielleicht fast drei Stunden her.
Wir mussten ja auch erst hierher kommen.
Musste ein Nachbarn fragen, dass er mich mit dem Auto hierher bricht.
Ich habe gar kein eigenes Auto.
Ja, sie kommen mit ihrem Nachbarn hier.
Der hat mich hierher gebracht.
Ja, aber der ist dann wieder weggefahren. Ja.
Alles klar.
Und.
Wie.
Wie hoch war das?
Wie kühlt ich?
Der wiegelt sich?
Na ja, der geht mir so.
So bis zur Brust.
Der ist vielleicht ein Meter hoch.
Ein Meter.
Ungefähr ein Meter, ja.
Ja.
Gab es andere Augenzeuge oder nur sie waren dort?
Ja, ich war natürlich alleine mit dem Kind.
Ja.
Und.
Nach diesem Umfall hat sie das Beus verloren.
Das Nebel weiß ich nicht.
Erst hat sie ja furchtbar geschrien.
Ja, nur geschrien.
Und sie hat mich aber eigentlich immer angeguckt und war dann aber so ein bisschen schläfrig.
Aber ich glaube, sie war schon.
Aber es schleume auf der Zunge vielleicht.
Schleume.
Schaum auf der Zunge?
Schaume, ja, Schaume auf der Zunge.
Nee, sowas hatte sie nicht.
Nein.
Oder hat sie auf die Zunge gebissen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Sie hat ja fast keine Zähne.
Ja.
Verstehe.
Und vor oder nach diesem Umfall ist ihnen etwas aufgefallen mit dem Baby?
Vorher, ja, da war sie wie immer.
Vorher, aber nach eher natürlich, da war sie ganz anders als sonst.
Sonst ist sie immer so ein unruhiges Kind und zappelig und und jetzt war sie
einfach ganz still und dann habe ich gedacht, ich muss ganz schnell zu ihnen kommen.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut.
Und dann ist sie dann, indem sie hierher gekommen sind.
Können Sie diesen Beule beschreiben?
Gab es Beule am Kopf?
Ja, ja, also das ist, jetzt muss ich überlegen, auf welcher Seite das ist?
Auf ihrer Augenblick, sie ist nach links runtergefallen.
Also auf ihrer rechten Seite am Kopf.
Hat sie, hat sie, sie hat ja wenig Haare und da sieht man, dass das so eine
große, große Beule ist, ja, dass das ganz unterlaufen ist, ganz blau.
Blau und habe sie auch eine Farbveränderung auf der Haut bemerkt?
Ja, diese Beule ist blau, ja, sage ich doch.
Ja, ich meine auf der Gesicht zum Beispiel.
Ja, vielleicht ist sie ein bisschen blass geworden.
Das könnte sein, aber bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher, sie sieht nie so gesund aus.
Aber hat sie nur geweint, ne?
Sie hat geweint, ja, ist also furchtbar geschrieben.
Und dann mit einmal hat sie aufgehört, mit schreien.
Ja, um sicherzugehen, werden wir zuerst bei ihr eine Rundgenaufnahme veranlassen.
Und danach können wir unser Gespräch wieder weitermachen.
Ah, ja, okay, ja.
Eine Rundgenaufnahme, das muss wirklich sein, wie hält sie denn still beim Rundgen?
Wie kriegen sie das denn hin?
Ja, es beinhaltet ein bisschen Rundgen, aber wir müssen auch sicher sein,
dass es keine Schaden bei ihr gibt.
Und gegebenenfalls können wir Ultraschall unter so hoch machen.
Ultraschall von was?
Ultraschall vom Kopf.
Um Beule richtig zu bewerten.
Ah, okay, ja, ja.
Und ich möchte auch noch ein paar Fragen über die Geburt.
Gab es an normalen Geburt?
Ja, das war schon ein schwieriges Kind von Frank-Al.
Also sie ist erst mal ein bisschen zu früh gekommen.
Also das waren so drei Wochen zu früh, drei Wochen vor dem Termin.
Und jetzt ja, wie vielte Woche?
Bitte?
Wie vielte Woche?
Ja, Ende der 36. Woche ist sie geboren.
Und war es ein normaler Geburt?
Oder?
Ja, ja, das waren die normalen Geburt.
Mit Kaiserschnitt?
Nein, nicht mit Kaiserschnitt.
Normaler Geburt.
Hat sie?
Aber nach dem Geburt ein Therapiebekommen?
Hat sie nach dem Geburt ein Therapiebekommen?
Ja, also deutlich später.
Man hat dann festgestellt, dass sie ein kleines Loch im Herzen hat.
Weil die das hat irgendwie nicht so richtig funktioniert mit der
mit der Blutung, mit der Lunge.
Und dann hat man sie operiert, als sie vier Monate war.
Und da musste sie operiert werden.
Bitte?
Ist der OP erfüllt?
Da hat man eine OP gemacht und da war sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus auf.
Ja, da war ich natürlich mit dabei.
Die OP war über Herzkammer oder Vorhauf, wissen Sie?
Ja, man sagt ein Loch im Herzen.
Und das wurde dann irgendwie geschlossen?
Alles klar.
Und ansonsten ist sie gesund, ne?
Ja, also sie ist kein einfaches Kind.
Sie schläft nachts nicht durch, sie trinkt alle Nase lang
und sie ist kein guter Esser.
Dann, wenn ich ihr Brei geben will, dann erst will sie, dann will sie nicht.
Und dann schubst sie es weg und so.
Und nachts schläft sie einfach nicht.
Sie wacht ständig auf.
Ich habe seit Monaten nicht mehr richtig durchgeschlafen.
Und wie füttern Sie hier?
Ja, sie, sie, sie, sie kriegt sie.
Nur mit Muttermilch, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe am Anfang habe ich mal versucht zu stillen,
aber das ging nicht gut.
Und dann kriegt sie Fläschchen jetzt, ne?
Was kriegt sie, bitte?
Sie kriegt die Flasche.
Also so, so angerührte Milch.
Seit wann?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Wochen probiert das mit dem stillen,
aber die hat ganz schlecht an der Brust getrunken
und dann habe ich das irgendwann sein gelassen.
Dann haben wir abgestillt und dann hat sie das Fläschchen bekommen.
Ich verstehe, aber davon kann ich Ihnen nur abraten,
weil wir empfehlen nur Muttermilch
während der Ärzte sechste Monaten.
Ja, aber wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann hat es noch keinen Wert.
Na?
Ja, aber sie können nicht alle Milchprodukte
in den Kuhmilch verdauen deswegen.
Nee, natürlich kriegt sie keine Kuhmilch.
Sie kriegt so Alete Milch, ne?
Ja, verstehe.
Und das Medikamente, die jetzt sie auch benutzen?
Nein, nein, nein, im Augenblick kriegt sie keine.
Sie kriegt diese Vitamin D Tropfen, ne?
Aber sonst kriegt sie nichts.
Ja.
Soweit Sie wissen, hat sie Allergien oder Verträglichkeiten?
Hat man bisher noch nichts festgestellt, das fehlt mir auch noch.
Und ich möchte auch noch ein paar Fragen über Ihr Lebensgewohnheiten.
Frau Aldeck, rauchen Sie?
Ich selber, ja, also in der Schwangerschaft
habe ich dann versucht weniger zu rauchen.
Das hat auch ganz gut geklappt.
Aber jetzt, wo sie auf der Welt ist,
rauche ich jetzt ja, rauche ich jetzt auch wieder so viel,
ungefähr so viel wie vorher.
Ja, zehn Jahre habe ich ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht
und dann in der Schwangerschaft habe ich das schön reduziert.
Da habe ich zwar nicht ganz aufgeraucht.
Aber Sie haben immer noch geraucht, na, während der Schwangerschaft?
Ja, aber viel weniger als vorher.
Wie viel ungefähr?
Ja, so vielleicht so vier, fünf Zigaretten am Tag,
vielleicht auch mal eine mehr.
Und dann aber, als ich, als ich wieder, als sie auf der Welt war,
da wollte ich eigentlich weniger rauchen.
Aber dann war so viel Stress und dann habe ich halt irgendwie wieder
angefangen, das rauche ich so.
Ja, kein ganzes Päckchen am Tag, aber so 15 Zigaretten
rauche ich schon am Tag.
Aber das ist auch nicht schön, ich muss zugeben.
Ja, ob das schön ist, aber ich habe so einen Stress.
Also, als allein erziehende Mutter, da hat man es einfach nicht so leicht
und da muss man, der wenigstens, mal eine Zigarette rauchen.
Sind Sie nicht verheiratet dann, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Und der Vater des Kindes hat sich auch sehr schnell zurückgezogen.
Das heißt, ich habe ihm gesagt, er darf nicht mehr hinkommen.
Wann ist das passiert?
Was?
Die Trennung?
Ja, da war die kleine, ein paar Monate auf der Welt.
Und, und ja, er hat immer getrunken und hat sich überhaupt nicht
um die Maris gekümmert.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, komm, lass uns in Ruhe.
Ist besser, wenn wir alleine klarkommen.
Dann kann ich mich wenigstens drauf verlassen, was passiert.
Jetzt musst du ja schwer gewesen sein für Sie.
Ja, es ist natürlich nicht das, was man sich wünscht, ja.
Deswegen bin ich auch ziemlich genervt, ja.
Trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, eigentlich schon so gut wie gar nicht, würde ich sagen.
Aber früher hatten Sie Gerach.
früher, klar, habe ich mal ein bisschen getrunken, ja.
Aber eigentlich dann in der Schwangerschaft nicht mehr.
Und jetzt, also, eigentlich trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Ja, ist klar.
Während schon in der Schacht haben Sie nicht getrunken.
Nein, nein.
Und mit der fühlen Sie sich nicht angegriffen,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, also das habe ich nie gemacht. Nein.
Gut.
Und ich möchte noch auch ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Krankungen. Wie sind, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Ich? Nein, eigentlich war ich bisher immer ganz gesund.
Ja. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 27.
Und Ihr Vater?
Ist der auch gesund? Nein.
Mein Vater oder Marys Vater?
Ja, wie gesagt, der hat zwar getrunken und so viel ich weiß,
hat der ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich verstehe.
Und Ihre Marys Oma oder Opa, sind Sie noch am Leben?
Ja, ja, klar.
Meine Eltern leben noch, weil von den Eltern,
von ihrem Vater weiß ich eigentlich gar nichts.
Aber mein Vater, der hat Zuckerkraumkeit,
so was man so im späteren Alter halt kriegt.
Und bei meiner Mutter hat er weiß ich,
dass die auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat,
dann nimmt sie irgendwelche Tabletten.
Und sie hat Probleme mit den Gelenken.
Also sie hat Arthritis.
Arthritis.
Klar.
Wir sind fast fertig.
Jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar Fragen über Ihre Sozialleben stellen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, also ich bin natürlich viel zu Hause,
aber ich habe ein paar Stunden, arbeite ich bei einer Spedition.
Wo genau?
Bei einer Spedition.
Was machen Sie dort gerade?
Ja, ich mache da Telefondienst und so ein bisschen Abrechnung.
Alles klar.
Und noch eine Frage,
brauchen Sie zu Hause oder auf dem Balkon draußen?
Also meistens auf dem Balkon,
aber manchmal bin ich einfach zu müde,
dann rauche ich auch mal in der Küche oder so.
Aber ich muss auch wiederholen,
Sie können sowohl für Sie als auch für Ihr Baby,
nicht zu Hause, auch mindestens draußen auf dem Balkon.
Was aber ganz schön kalt jetzt bei den Wetter.
Ja, aber das ist auch gefährlich, ganz schädlich.
Und wir sind jetzt am Ende unseres Gesprächs
und um sicher zu gehen,
möchte ich ein paar Apparate diagnostisch bei Ihr durchführen
und einmal Volute abnehmen.
Auch die kleine Musik, die pikt werden, das ist aber schlimm.
Ja, eines kleines Pics, aber nichts so hart.
Und zur Sicherheit,
wir haben für 48 Stunden mindestens hier Leiben zu Beobachtung.
Oh, so lange.
Ja, das ist eine Routine.
Und je nach dem Ergebnis können wir widersprechen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, wird Sie dann wieder fit?
Was meinen Sie? Fängt Sie wieder an, dass Sie wieder runter wird?
Weil wie lange dauert, dass Sie wieder wach wird?
Ich glaube, ist es nicht Schlimmes passiert
und die Beule kann einfach passieren.
Aber ich möchte auch ausschließen,
dass es etwas gefährlich ist.
Ja, okay.
Bis gleich.
Abonniere Kollegen oder Kollegen und andere Fragen.
Es war ein sehr schwieriger Fall für mich.
Ja, schreck mich. Für mich auch.
Wie gesagt, das ist nicht meine Welt.
Wirklich.
Erst mal habe ich gehört.
Aber Sie wissen jetzt, was es ist.
Ja, ich habe schon gelernt.
Ja, der Wirklich.
Heute werden die Kinder gar nicht mehr so eingewickelt.
Sie bekommen nur ihre Pampers um und werden die zugeklebt.
Früher hat man noch Windeln umgewickelt.
Ich habe das noch bei meinen.
Über die Papier oder Plastikwindeln
haben wir immer noch zum Breitwickeln Stoffwindeln gemacht.
Dann eine Hose drüber,
damit die schön breit gewickelt sind.
Das ist ein sehr guter Weg.
Da wurde noch gewickelt.
Bei den neuen Klebewindeln macht man das gar nicht mehr.
Stillenernehrung.
Ja.
Sie hat jetzt gesagt, sie stillen nicht.
Sondern sie gibt das Fläschchen.
Da hat der Doktor gesagt,
das wäre aber jetzt gut, wenn sie noch weiter stillen würden.
Aber wenn der Zug abgefahren ist, dann ist es vorbei.
Dann ist Schluss.
Dann geht es halt nicht mehr.
Ich habe tatsächlich noch eine Information,
die ihr nicht gefragt habt.
Welche denn?
Sie hat erbrochen die Kleine.
Das habe ich Ihnen noch nicht erzählt.
Sie hat drei Mal gefragt.
Ich habe es selbst vergessen.
Ich sehe es jetzt gerade.
Sie haben auch nicht gefragt danach.
Ich sehe mich nicht gefragt.
Da müsste man in dem Zusammenhang auch fragen.
Spuckt sie sonst viel?
Es gibt ja Kinder,
die sich nicht mehr überlegen,
sondern es gibt ja Kinder, die spucken wie verrückt.
Da hat man immer ein Tuch auf der Schulter liegen.
Weil man sonst ständig voll gekotzt ist.
Andere Kinder
brauchen das überhaupt nicht.
Die spucken gar nicht.
Bei diesem Kind würde ich jetzt einfach mal,
das ist ja so kribbelig.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Das ist ein bisschen spuckkind.
Dann denke ich,
dass das auch gar nicht so besonders für die Mutter ist.
Wenn das Kind jetzt mal ein bisschen gespuckt hat.
Aber tatsächlich hat sie ...
Eine Frage könnte so sein.
Verschluckt sie sich oft?
Ja.
Das ist passiert natürlich bei der Flasche.
Viel schneller als beim Stillen.
Beim Stillen müssen die Kinder viel mehr arbeiten
und verschlucken sich nicht so leicht.
Bei der Flasche kommt viel mehr raus.
Dann kriegen die halt so viel.
Dann können sie sich verschlucken.
Dann müssen sie Bäuerchen machen.
Dann kommt oft mal so ein Schwabchen mit raus.
Ich denke, eine Frage
ist, dass die Kinder die Kinder
in der Flasche arbeiten.
Das ist die Frage.
Was ist das für eine Frage?
Was ist die Frage?
Wie meine Frage?
Eine Typ gibt es zum Beispiel.
Mama hat gesagt,
dass sie vorher getrunken Alkohol
getrunken Alkohol hat.
Und jetzt momentan
wir nicht wissen,
dass Mama getrunken Alkohol hat.
Sie hat ja gesagt, sie trinkt nicht.
Sie hat eigentlich gesagt, Alkohol ist kein Problem.
Aber natürlich war sie auch schon ein bisschen genervt.
Weil ja, der Doktor schon gesagt hat,
dass mit dem Rauchen ist schlecht.
Wenn man dann schon mal gesagt bekommen hat,
das ist aber blöd, dass sie rauchen.
Dann sagt man halt hinterher,
vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt,
dass man doch hin und wieder die Kinder trinken.
Aber ich würde jetzt hier einfach mal davon ausgehen,
dass das schon korrekt ist,
dass sie wirklich nicht getrunken hat in der Spangerschaft
und früher auch nicht exzessiv getrunken hat.
Ich würde mal sagen,
wie alle Durchschnittsdeutschen bei irgendeinem Fest
oder einer Party trinken.
Man trinkt mal einen Schluck Alkohol.
Oder auch ein Schluck Alkohol.
Aber das hat ja nichts mit Alkoholabusos zu tun.
In der Türkei diese Fall,
eine Stimmungprobleme,
eine Pistöische Probleme,
viele Sehen,
ich habe mir gesehen,
ihre Mutter,
die die Kinder trinken,
die ihre Mutter
problematisch.
Sicherlich ist diese Frau ja auch ein bisschen problematisch.
Keine Frage.
Sie ist ja so ein bisschen wurschtig.
Also so,
ist ja eigentlich alles ein bisschen egal.
Jetzt hat sie aber natürlich Angst,
weil das Kind komisch ist.
Aber sie ist genervt von dem Kind.
Sie ist genervt von dem Kind, weil es nicht schläft.
Und sie ist genervt, weil es nicht gut ist.
Eine Typ und Erfahrung,
ein Meter
oder wickeltisch,
maximum ein Meter oder 40 cm
wickeltisch.
50 cm ist das eine Menge.
50 cm wickeltisch.
50 cm ist viel zu wenig.
Man hat das Kind eigentlich immer so relativ hoch,
dass man sich nicht bücken muss.
Also ich denke, der ist höher als ein normaler Tisch.
Und
Kopf, Kopf, Baby,
keine
Hart
und deswegen
eine Hematom gibt es möglich, aber
keine Faktoren.
Eine Faktore, keine
Hematom.
Mit der Faktur muss man nicht rechnen, weil die Birne wirklich noch weich ist.
Die haben wirklich noch einen weichen Kopf zu Kindern.
Und insofern
ist ja auch die Frage, ob das Röntgen ist.
Und ob wahrscheinlich Langdian Ultraschalen.
Aber das kriegen wir ja gleich erst mal im Arztgespräch raus.
Ja, okay.
Wir anfangen.
Noch eine Frage.
Hatte sie keine Fieber?
Hat sie nicht gemessen natürlich.
Also mal ehrlich, wenn Ihnen das Kind von wickeltisch fällt,
dann messen Sie kein Fieber.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Nein, ja.
Okay.
Frau Oberstein, herzten Sie kurz Zeit für mich.
Ich habe aber eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Frau Waldeck-Marie.
Frau Waldeck-Marie ist eine 6-monatige Säugling.
Heute kranken Sie uns
mit Ihrer Mutter
und die Begleitung
von Eure Nachbarn
wegen vor 3 Stunden
passierten Sturz auf dem wickeltisch.
Auf dem wickeltisch?
Auf dem wickeltisch.
Aus dem.
Vom wickeltisch.
Die Höhe vom wickeltisch war ungefähr 1 Meter.
Und
Sie haben
die Mutter hat eine Beule
auf der rechten Seite des Kopfes
und beleuliche Verfahrung bemerkt.
Nach dem Umfall
habe Sie das
Zeugling viel geweint
und belastet.
Verbrochen
und laut der Mutter
apathisch geworden.
Und haben Sie dann gleich
eine Beleulichung von
einem Kind?
Nein,
habe ich vergessen,
aber werde ich
während der Körperdurchsuchung sofort messen.
Ist das Kind denn immer noch so schlapp
und apathisch?
Ja.
Da müsste man sicherlich fix dran.
Natürlich.
Und die Frage nach
über die Sinkgruppe,
die Schräumung und Blutungen wurden vereint.
In der Vegetative
an Amnese, in Zoni, seit Langem
und
über die Geburt.
Es war ein normales Geburt,
aber es war früh ein normales Geburt.
Bei
36. Schwangerschaftsbruch
und
eine
Operation aufgrund von Herzloh.
Wie nennt man das?
Realistisch.
Ich bin mir nicht das, ich heiße Svizio.
Herzvizio.
Ja, meine ich ja.
Die Mutter konnte nur
zwei Wochen das Baby gestillen.
Sie konnte stillen?
Ja, aber
ab zweiter Woche
erneut sie mit Flaschen
mit Schusettik.
Sie nehmen Vitamin D.
Sie nehmen
keine Allergien.
Die Mutter
vor der Schwangerschaft
hat ungefähr einpackung vor
10 Jahren geraucht.
Die Nikotin Konsum
ist reduziert.
Aber
noch macht weiter.
Und ungefähr 50erer
pro Tag
während der Schwangerschaft.
Sie ist auch Ex-Trinkeerin.
Aber es besteht
keine Alkoholkonsum-Werte-Schwangerschaft.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde vereint.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Vater ist Alkoholiker.
Und Artealhypertonie.
Mütterlicherseits
Hopa leidet an Diabetes-Militus
und Homa Artealhypertonium Arthritis.
Die Mutter der Patientin
sei getrennt vor
den Diabetes-Militus.
Sie ist getrennt vor
vier Monaten.
Sie arbeitet
im Telefondienst.
Auf den alarmistischen Angaben
habe ich ein Verdacht
auf Komotion-Zerebri-
bzw. Gehehen-Esschütterung.
Als Differenzialdiagnose
denke ich, sie ist in Gruppe.
Sie ist in der Erdbeutung
oder Leid eines Kindesmissbrauchs.
Um sicherzugehen,
zur Absicherung der Diagnose,
möchte ich
ein Ultraschall des Kopfes
und ein Grundgern des Kopfes veranlassen.
Machen Sie aber
die körperliche Untersuchung?
Ja, natürlich.
Worauf achten Sie alles
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Das ist eine sehr komplexe Geschichte.
Als Erstes
möchte ich Untersuchern
die Haut auf Narben,
Exkoreationen,
vielleicht Blutungen
während dieser Umfall.
Es könnte auch Hinweis
über Missbrauch.
Oder Misshandlung?
Ja, Misshandlung.
Bei der Palpation
habe ich
Beutung abtasten.
Die Beutung?
Ja.
Mindestens 2 Tage
für 48 Stunden
muss sie hierbleiben.
Wir müssen beobachten.
Aber wo nachschauen Sie den Loch
im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ist das Kind immer noch apathisch?
Ja, wenn die Kinder stabil sein
ist, dann können wir sie
entlassen.
Aber wenn sie apathisch geht,
dann können wir sie untersuchen.
Dann müssen Sie noch
mehr gucken,
als nur, wie die Beule aussieht
und den Kopf abtasten.
Was müssen Sie
machen?
Ich würde auch die Frontanelle untersuchen.
Ja,
aber einem Kind ist noch mehr dran.
ich gucke, ob es ein Hämatom dort gibt.
Wo?
Im Kopf zwischen
Subarabnoidalraum
und dann den Kopf untersuchen.
Aber Sie müssen das ganze Kind untersuchen.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie wollen nach Narben gucken
und nach Runden.
Aber was müssen Sie noch machen?
Ein Kind, das relativ schlapp dar liegt.
Die Farbveränderung.
Wie fährst du mit Reflexen?
Das sind neuropologische Sachen.
Ob das Kind
Schmerzreize hat.
Ob es Pupillenreize hat.
Ob die Pupillen auf Licht reagieren.
Sie müssen noch die neuropologischen Reflexe untersuchen.
Ob sie eine pathologische Reflexe hat.
Ja.
Und die Augen
müssen auch gucken, ob die Augen vertrecht ist.
Oder normal ist.
Ja.
Ob die Pupillenreaktion ist.
Muss man einmal reingeglicken.
Ja.
Und natürlich die Vitalparameter.
Überwachen.
Und wir müssen auch sicher sein,
dass es keine Blutung
im Inneren Organe gibt.
Dafür sollen wir auch
ein Ultraschall des Bauches.
Und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
können wir auch die Beweglichkeit
der Extremitäten überprüfen.
Genau.
Ob es irgendwie Widerstand gibt,
ob sie reagiert, Schmerzreize hat.
Ja.
Ob sie gläut eine Nackensteifigkeit hat.
Okay.
Genau.
Da ist schon einiges zu untersuchen.
Was machen Sie noch?
Sie wollen Blut abnehmen.
Was wollen Sie im Labor untersuchen?
Was kann man da untersuchen?
Ja, weil sie mit Trauma her
hergekommen ist.
Eine Entzündung,
wie man den geht, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Genau.
Ich möchte auch die Vitalorganen
wie Labor oder
Labanieren auch
können wir sehen, die Werte.
Im Ultraschall.
Im Labor.
Kann man einen Rundumschlag machen,
dass man guckt, ist das Kind
ansonsten gar nicht gesund.
Das machen Sie.
Das Kind wird 48 Stunden überwacht.
Was machen Sie mit dem Kind,
außer es zu anderen
ist,
zu angucken?
Das Kind
außer es zu angucken.
Das Kind zu den Pediatrischen.
Und vielleicht eine
forensische Konzik.
Auch noch?
Ja.
Ich möchte Jugendamts melden.
Soll ich das machen?
Ja, ich will das machen.
Jugendamt ist ein bisschen
hochgegriffen.
Aber in diesem Fall der beschrieben ist,
wurde angeregt,
den Sozialdienst zu informieren.
Weil die Mutter
selber Überforderungskennzeichen hat.
Sie sagt selber, sie schläft nachts nicht.
Sie hat seit Wochen nicht durchgeschlagen.
Das Kind nervt sie.
Es ist anstrengend.
Allein erzieht.
Sie ist alleinerziehend.
Das Kind hat ja auch Startprobleme.
Es ist zu früh gekommen.
Es hatte diese Herz-OP.
Das hatte schon einen schlechten Start.
Es war ein bisschen zu lang.
Dass man über den Sozialdienst Hilfe anbietet.
Diese Mutter.
Sie holt damit auch runter.
Sie entlastet.
Gibt es noch routine Maßnahmen,
die wir machen müssen?
In diesem Fall?
Ich habe als Therapie
intensive Überwachung.
Dann haben die gesagt, Zugang leben.
Gegebenenfalls Flüssigkeitszufuhr.
Wenn das mit einem Trinken nicht ohne weiteres funktioniert.
Bettruhe.
Was die noch gesagt haben,
zum Abschwellen eines potenziellen
Potentialen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Eine potenzielle Komotio.
Dass man sagt,
Kortigoide.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch
Stand der Wissenschaft ist.
Meine Infos sind auch limitiert.
Ich habe kein Medizin studiert.
Das haben wir noch nicht.
Ich habe keine Medizin studiert.
Das haben die geschrieben.
Aber sicherlich muss man
das Kind überwachen.
Und gucken, dass es eben Ruhe erhält.
Wenn es nicht gut trinkt,
muss man ein bisschen nachher
mit Externat zuvor.
Ich glaube,
dass nicht trinken ist eine Warnzeichen.
Ja, klar.
Das hat die Mutter ja auch eigentlich
gewundert.
Sonst will sie ständig trinken.
Dann trinkt sie aber nicht gut.
Jetzt will sie gar nicht trinken.
Gut.
Ich würde sagen,
gemeinschaftlich können wir zu dem Ergebnis kommen.
Dass das ein natürlich schwieriger Fall ist.
Es ist ein schwieriger Fall
aufgrund der Konstellation.
Weil es eine problematische Situation ist.
Es ist eine sensible Situation.
Weil immer im Hinterkopf dieser Gedanke ist,
wird ein Kind zu Hause nicht angemessen.
Weil es immer so im Hinterkopf ist,
wird ein Kind zu Hause nicht angemessen behandelt.
Das ist natürlich was,
womit man die Mutter jetzt nicht
knallhart konfrontieren kann.
Sondern da muss man sehr subtil fragen.
Das ist das eine.
Von der Geschichte her
ist dieses natürlich ein schwieriger Fall.
Mit der
zu frühem Geburt, mit dem Vizium,
mit dem Alkoholkonsum des Vaters,
mit dem potentiellen Nikotinkonsum.
Übrigens, was die Mutter weit von sich weisen würde,
dass sie Extrinkerin ist.
Ja?
Also jemand, der mal Alkohol trinkt,
gilt in Deutschland nicht als Trinker.
Ja?
Trinker ist Definition Alkoholabusus.
Sie hat früher Alkohol gelegen,
nicht Alkohol getrunken.
Aber in der Schwangerschaft nicht mehr.
Das ist sicherlich eine absolute
Fehldarstellung.
Sie kommt nicht in Begleitung des Nachbarn,
sondern der Nachbar, der in der
Schwangerschaft ist,
ist dann wieder weggefahren.
Es ist also jetzt für sie auch kein Ansprechpartner.
Ja?
Das ist glaube ich eine wichtige Sache,
weil das irgendwie zeigt,
dass diese Frau mächtig alleine ist mit ihrem Kind.
Ja?
Und eigentlich keine Unterstützung hat.
Gut.
Was ich wirklich elementar wichtig finde
für diesen Fall,
dass man im Gespräch,
ganz klar, wenn die erste Schilderung kommt,
dass man abricht und sagt,
ich gucke mir das Kind jetzt erst mal an.
Sie können nicht nach Oma und Opa fragen
und das Kind nicht da immer noch und legt die Ohren an.
Das geht nicht.
Wie soll das Lebenszeichen überprüfen danach?
Ja, und auch wirklich eine
erste grobe Untersuchung machen
und sagen, wir unterhalten uns gleich weiter.
Aber so sicherlich ist das wichtig,
dass da erstmal jemand
wirklich ein fachmännisches Auge drauf wirft.
Ja?
Und wenn man selber sagt,
wir rufen den pediatricen Notdienst an, ja?
Weiß ich nicht, ob das
in so einer Ambulanzsituation möglich ist, ja?
Und in so einer Prüfungssituation,
aber da würde ich tatsächlich sagen,
wenn so jemand kommt,
würde ich gucken,
wir haben den Pediatra dazu.
Wir sind hier in diesem Fall als
Nordarzt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber dann muss man sagen,
jetzt gucke ich das Kind erst mal an
und nachher frage ich weiter.
Nicht, dass das Kind inzwischen blau geworden ist
oder wie da nichts mehr sagt.
Gut.
Also, zugegeben,
ein richtig schwieriger Fall
für Sie, für mich.
Ja.
Und ich würde sagen,
es ist nicht so gut gelaufen wie beim letzten Mal.
Beim letzten Mal waren Sie sehr,
sehr gut in der Anamnese und in Bericht.
Und man hat jetzt gemerkt,
das ist nicht Ihr Wohlfühlgebiet, ja?
Und insofern war das nicht
ganz so souverän.
Ich würde sagen,
gucken Sie sich diesen Fall einfach nochmal in Ruhe an.
Und Sie haben das,
Sie haben den wahrscheinlich in schriftlicher Form vorliegen,
ne?
Ja, aber das habe ich noch nicht gelesen.
Ja, also gucken Sie sich den nochmal in Ruhe an,
weil der Kollege da eigentlich auch nochmal ziemlich viel
oder die Kollegin ziemlich viel
Randinformationen mit dazugegeben hat.
Und es war ein Hannover Fall.
Ja? Ja.
Okay.
Ja, das ist richtig.